Este es mi hermana Adriana maricel
Zambrano con 28 años Fue asesinada tenía
mucho para vivir Tenía muchos Sueños por
cumplir tenía dos hijas y una familia
que la amaba
luego del homicidio que ocurrió en 2008
el asesino su expareja pasó tan solo dos
años y medio en prisión para nosotros
fue muy doloroso porque no no no no
teníamos Consuelo para nosotros una fue
una burla esa condena
Adriana Zambrano le da su nombre el
observatorio de femicidios que mantiene
la ong la casa del encuentro que presta
asistencia a mujeres Víctimas de
violencia desde el observatorio de
femicidios nosotras presentamos dos
libros uno con los primeros cinco años
de informes y otro que presentamos en el
2020 con los 10 años de informes de
femicidios y transfemicidios en nuestro
país a pesar de que hubo grandes avances
en la normativa Argentina a la rico es
crítica de lo que ocurre en materia de
violencia contra las mujeres porque las
mujeres las siguen matando Porque desde
el año 2008 una mujer es asesinada cada
30 horas y eso no desciende todo esto en
un contexto de Gran concientización
social en el que el movimiento de
mujeres ha crecido en años recientes con
fuertes consignas contra la violencia
uno de los problemas tiene que ver con
la respuesta coordinada de todas las
estructuras del Estado algo que perciben
en la oficina de la mujer de la Corte
Suprema de Justicia de Argentina si el
estado pudiera responder a la primera
acercamiento de una víctima a pedir
ayuda seguramente el resultado no sería
la muerte porque el femicidio es la
punta del iceberg de la violencia contra
la mujer algo que frena a tiempo podría
evitar que sigan repitiéndose muertes
como la de Adriana Zambrano y otros
tantos miles de mujeres